have whipped themselves up a portion of
this generation into believing literally
that they are going to burn to death
within their lifetimes
um but welcome back for now to
protesters from just stop oil who spent
11 days demonstrating in London blocking
roads throwing painted shops and
restaurants today a fire engine and an
ambulance were briefly caught up in
their blockade prompting the British
government to save this kind of protest
isn't acceptable what Jenny Cleveland's
still with me I'm joined by the talk to
the contributor Richard ties and from
just stop oil a James key Mrs Keith
welcome thank you very much for coming
in appreciate it at what point when
you're blocking fire engines and
ambulances are you concerned about lives
being cost lost by what you're doing
well the whole reason we're doing this
is because we're concerned about the
lives but you get the irony that if
you're actually stopping ambulances and
fire engines is going to save people's
lives they may actually die because of
your protest well actually we have a
blue light policy we're let through
every emergency vehicle you didn't know
and if you actually cared to run the
whole footage there you'd see that that
ambulance um is advised by one of our
people to avoid the roadblock and the
the fight
out of the way you have no right you
have absolutely no right to obstruct
other people's daily lives you have the
right to protest on the side of the
street you are unlawfully in the middle
of the street it's utterly outrageous
it's selfish and you are putting
people's lives at risk I I appreciate
your frustration and I understand that I
empathize with that but look we are
demanding that the the government hold
any new licensing and consent for any
fossil fuel exploration in the UK now
you know that that needs to happen
it does need to happen
if we need to ensure millions of people
living on this planet the United Nations
because of cheap energy from fossil
fuels you can't get cheaper than free
all right okay Renewables are nine times
cheaper than you was not free we spend
15 billion subsidizing Renewables
we spend 236 million pounds a week
and by the way he's not frustrated he's
Furious right my question remains though
with you where is your moral line with
this you say you want to save lives and
yet your actions are bordering on
potentially costing lives you cannot get
in the way of Emergency Services in the
way that you're doing and if you do want
to explain the moral difference between
what you're doing and what you complain
everyone's doing about the planet
well I mean let's look if we want to
talk about disruption and earlier
that the fire brigade the lunar fire
brigade had their busiest day since the
blitz okay 60 UK families lost their
houses and wildfires why are we not
talking about them why are we
concentrating on such a small bit of
Destruction
disruption is nothing in comparison to
what's coming here and you know it you
know it you think it's small I say to
you you have no idea the damage you're
doing when you get in the way of
Emergency Services
my question is why is no emergency why
are the lives of the people who you're
putting at risk by stopping those fire
engines why are you why are you
manipulating your audience
Miss Freeman finish my question why are
the lives of the people who whose lives
may be affected by your actions today
why are they less important to you than
the lives that you say will be cost by
not taking climate change more seriously
I value everyone's life
absolutely stop lying yourself
for the record I agree with you I think
it's ridiculous it's down to nurses
doctors bartenders and whatnot to be
going out in the street and demanding
what the government should just be doing
anyway right this is this is just on the
side because it wouldn't work wait wait
wait I'm not saying I'm against your
cause I'm really getting against your
methodology doesn't it I don't think it
does open history book I don't think
it's suffrageous it doesn't work highly
disrupted Civil Rights Movement highly
disruptive gay rights highly disruptive
you know it works you're a journalist
you've done your research you know this
let me finish we wouldn't be on here
I don't think it works when you're lying
in front of Emergency Services I don't I
don't you will lose the British public
and my concern for you guys you keep
thinking any disruption is valid and any
disruption works and I'm gonna say to
you yes you're on this show but you're
on this show because people are
absolutely Furious yeah you got in the
way of ambulances and fire engines and I
say you can do both gun you you can make
vociferous protests but you don't have
to get in the way of things that are
saving people's lives why don't you tell
your audience about the the actual
disruption that's coming on Down the
Line why don't you bring qualified
climate scientists on here to explain
what civilizational collapse looks like
all right we've lost a third of our
wheat yields this year we're projected
to lose 50 percent of our potato Harvest
if it's this bad in 2022 how bad is it
going to be in 2050 you know if we have
food shortages that leads to
civilization of collapse I'm sorry I'm
sorry
you're objectively
you are lying we yielded on a third
degree in this country it means I didn't
have to go abroad it hit 40. you
deranged are you hit 40 degrees are you
selfish why do you want to protest
because because we have no choice
because we're in a diet situation pay
attention
because at the moment you are not paying
attention to what's absolutely paying
attention Okay but look I mean look here
you have
a woman who's tried to say goodbye to
her mum who's 90 years old
be the most important day potentially
you've ever had in your life yes
and ends up with 10 minutes a funeral
lasting 10 minutes for her mother and
that's directly because of the stop the
oil protest which shut down the motorway
the best friend of her mother couldn't
even get there to say goodbye to her a
great friend
do you feel any sense of remorse about
that when you hear it I mean there's
some firstly my deepest condolences as
well
I think the problem is here is you were
talking about uh electing and
re-electing governments but we don't
have the time for that so if we're
talking about the Net Zero targets that
the government have put in place which
the Judiciary have just ruled unlawful
that's in 28 years time and our country
is burning okay we've literally seen
that this week we've seen people die
because of the Heat and it's just going
to get worse the whole of Europe is
burning and is on fire and there are
ways there are ways to make that point
you're not generally determining how
many people are going to die and suffer
over the coming decades we're going to
talk we're talking about you know what
kind of a future your children your
children would you replace would you
write about that government don't care
right okay I mean how Draconian would
you be would you cut the oil Roth right
now what we're saying is no new oil and
gas
would you cut it off right now no that
would be total chaos but by the
government's own reports we have eight
years boiling gas reserves left that's
plenty of time to transition away from
that into something that's sustainable
and that actually gives our generation a
future I mean we're already seeing the
impacts this isn't something that's
going to happen in 10 20 years do you
really think members of the public are
going to listen in any way shape or form
to you when you do the accent that you
do and you're breaking the law so how
how can you give any any advice that's
compelling or build an argument and
bring people into that argument and try
and persuade them when you're actually
talking about this is the point you see
so I think my overriding view of these
people is the more of this they do
whatever the merits of the calls that
they're fighting for which is climate
change and about the over excessive use
of oil around the world it's eroding by
the second with these acts of childish
Petty pathetic vandalism Am I Wrong
anyone want to defend these people well
I'd personally say that I agree that
that kind of Act is not helpful for the
cause at all it makes it look like it's
all a kind of teenage protest and a kind
of sulky teenager pouting if you like
um but at the same time I think that it
also reflects deep concern about what
the UK is going to do next on this front
um the UK did have a pretty sensible set
of policies
um one of the many things that appeared
to be happening under trust was that
some of these were being reversed and so
at the same time as saying that this
kind of act probably milked down in the
supermarket is pretty dumb it's equally
dumb to not have some kind of coherent
government policy to switch rapidly to
renewable energy I mean these things can
both be true I mean my view about the
renewable energy of the fossil fuels is
you can't do it all in one go and my God
we've discovered this year that the
energy situation is pretty desperate for
everyone and in the short term we need
fossil fuels just to survive but we are
going to have to try as a planet to move
to Renewables the issue at the moment is
cost and availability right yes
absolutely but I don't think that these
guys should be part of that debate
that's a serious debate for serious
people and when I look at that picture
of them throwing paint at Van Gogh
sunflowers I felt anger internally and
that's what they wanted me to feel if
you think about their protests attacking
The cenotaph Dumping a bucket of feces
over a statue of Captain Tom they are
not actually as childish as you think
they are carefully designed to provoke
an emotional reaction of Fury in the
British people it's a bit like when the
vegans start in the extreme vegan start
shrieking away and doing Mad things it
makes me want to go and order a Big Mac
if you're young and you're angry about
what's going on and you believe a lot of
eminent scientists who say we are fading
potential catastrophe and you think your
government is not stepping up then what
are you left to do you should stand for
election it's the idea that because
people aren't listening we have the
right to to stop other people going
about their law-abiding business and to
force governments to do something they
say we need a conversation we talk
incessantly about this okay well let's
bring in Douglas yeah also appears if I
can say who are the people you would go
to last for some long-term projections I
would have said people who've been on
the planet the least amount of time
we're talking here about people we're
talking here about people who don't know
that it was hot in the 1970s in the
summer 1976 was a pretty hot summer they
they have been told they have whipped
themselves up a portion of this
generation into believing literally that
they are going to burn to death within
their lifetimes they are lying to
themselves and lying to other people
they are whipping themselves up into a
fury and here's the thing there are
actually consequences from the adults
listening to the kids look what's
happening in Germany and in France look
at the dependency on Russian gas look at
the way in which France and Germany
through short term is the green imbued
policies have ended up firstly being
completely in Hawk to have Vladimir
Putin and secondly seeing what many of
us said was going to be the consequence
all along look at the German green party
that that's one of these radical parties
recently they've had to admit oh we do
need oil and gas The Next Step they're
going to have to do is oh we need
nuclear yes because that's what happens
when you grow up and learn okay let's
bring in Jenny I mean you can see what's
happening in Sri Lanka for example where
the government came in and they tried to
go down a very aggressive green policy
route and now you've got all hell
breaking leads well that's because the
economy is in a state I would say that
young people are the people who are
going to have to live with the
consequences of our inaction that is the
truth of it quite a long time yes but
they're going to need a lot longer than
you people who are younger than you I
don't know the state of a lot of them
and I think they have a right to feel
very frustrated there are a lot of
vested interests in the world whose
priority is not uh tackling climate
change we don't want to be dependent on
countries that are quite grubby
countries like Saudi Arabia we need to
find alternative sources of energy for a
variety of political things I don't want
to burn to death most people don't want
to burn to death they're not going to
either the problem here is we're talking
about young kids who have been
indoctrinated into an incredibly extreme
ideology as I say we would have
recognized them during the Protestant
Reformation we'd have recognized them
during the Inquisition these are people
who believe they need to do anything to
achieve their goals because they
honestly believe they're going to go to
Hellfire in the next six months all of
their times trajectories keep on being
proven wrong all of their methodology
does nothing but irritate the general
public and all of their claims about the
speed with which we can get off fossil
fuels a flat out wrong Richard you're
not really a believer in climate change
of course I am I mean there's no
question that the climate has changed
since the Year Dot pins and it will
always continue to change and we quite
rightly as John has just said we're in a
warming phase the another we're in a
rapidly accelerating but what was
interesting about the the link to 1976
was back then we had 16 consecutive days
of over 30 degrees including five days
of over 35 degrees so we had a longer
period of very hot weather almost half a
century ago now we're getting what looks
like essentially short-term spikes but
initially back in the 70s there was more
concern about global cooling than global
warming so we're clearly in a cycle a
warming cycle that's you know that's
indisputable my point about climate
change is look it's been here since the
Year Dot it will always be here we
should absolutely affect what we can
affect which is emissions there are many
parts of climate change of course that
actually we have no we can have no
impact on for example solar variability
volcanic activity sea level oscillation
these are massive things totally out
with us when you've had the vast
majority of scientists saying this
planet is heating to a dangerous level
where we could potentially end up with
the extinction of the planet do you
believe them but I think we all know
that we are in a warming phase would you
believe them when they when they say I
think it'd be the end warming phase um I
think that look that may be overstating
it there's no question
all right let me ask you what's your
view about it well when I hear views
like this and words like warming phase I
feel like I don't know if you've seen
the film Wally but I feel like we're in
the some sort of archive in some
futuristic film where they look back of
how people spoke in that well there was
a movie came out last year which was a
spoof of all yes I feel like DiCaprio it
was brilliant but it did feel a bit like
that's what's going on and I think it's
driven a lot by social media isn't it it
is you see the same people that were
saying Cove is just a flu and they're
out again with their flags and they're
waving this down as well I think is that
what we want to see people see what they
want to see and uh people want to have
this illusion that we can control
everything and this feeling like
everything is out of control when I
looked at the weather forecast last week
for where I live and saw 40 degrees it
really frightened me because we always
feel like climate change is something or
the climate emergency is on the horizon
but we're living in it we have you know
Railways saying that the national rail
saying we have to re-engineer the
railways water companies putting out
warnings this is it now and I think we
can't dress this up in we're in a
warming cycle I mean this is it we're
living in it now okay let's just talk
the reality is we don't know that we're
clearly in a warming cycle we don't but
what we do know is that is that the vast
vast majority yeah of course scientists
are all predicting pretty much the same
thing if we don't as a planet get our
act but the point is there are many
parts of climate change that the reality
is we have we cannot control at all as I
just touched on there are parts that we
can do like emissions reduction and we
should be doing that and actually I
think we're making you know we're making
positive steps towards that